So here's the answer. Initially we create a restaurant object and we see that it
has the is yummy method we defined that always returns false. But is yummy is
just an attribute we can assign that to something else. So let's create a new
function we'll call it real yummy that always returns true. And just to test it
really yummy returns true. So now what we really want to do is replace. The
value of the is yummy attribute of chez bananas with really yummy. And now when
we call this procedure well we're just calling the really yummy procedure
redefined. It always returns true. Note that there is a difference here. The is
yummy is a method and that implicitly is bound to this chez bananas object. The
really yummy takes no parameters, it's not a method, it's just a procedure that
always returns true. And I should have a very clear warning. Although we can do
this, it's really confusing. So please don't do this, don't reassign methods to
new values unless you've got a really, really good reason. And if you've got a
really good reason for wanting to do this kind of change, post it on the
discussion forums, and make sure that people agree that it's a really good
reason. There probably isn't one.